de la classe politique qui a pris la
place du colon jusqu'à présent le coup
d'état du 5 septembre n'a pas surpris
est-ce que c'était prévisible pour vous
également tu était tout à fait
prévisible puis deux années même avec
monsieur alpha condé deux pays étaient
dans une crise profonde à la fin de son
second mandat il a cherché par tous les
moyens y compris de moyens tout à fait
inadmissible à se maintenir au pouvoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
journée de mobilisation en tunisie des
milliers de manifestants sont descendus
dans la rue près de quatre mois après la
suspension du parlement le limogeage du
premier ministre est la reprise dans
l'angle du court 1 judiciaire par le
président sayyed
les protestataires dénoncent un coup
d'état
alléno maxime est confiné des deux mains
en autriche mesure inédite dans lieu
face à l'augmentation du nombre de cas
de contamination dans le pays a les
chiffres de l'épidémie repartent à la
hausse toute l'europe centrale et
concerner l'allemagne renforcent la
nécessité de se faire vacciner les pays
bas reviennent te fous du film en
partiel
[Musique]
de nouvelles sanctions contre la
biélorussie sont attendus les ministres
des affaires étrangères de lieux se
réunissent ce lundi bruxelles accuse
minsk d'instrumentaliser la question
migratoire alors que des milliers de
migrants compte à la frontière entre la
biélorussie et la pologne
la lumière jean se dit prêt à aider à
résoudre cette crise
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france
ils sont quelques 3000 à s'être
rassemblés aujourd'hui à proximité du
parlement tunisien en parlement gelé
depuis plus de trois mois des
protestataires qui dénoncent un coup
d'état de la part du président aura et
sayed il lui reproche de s'être arrogé
les pleins pouvoirs un important
dispositif de sécurité avait été déployé
pour l'occasion le récit des médias ce
qui fit
des milliers de manifestants rassemblés
devant le parlement tunisien une
mobilisation pour pointer du doigt ce
que les protestataires dénoncent comme
étant un coup d'état du président kaïs
saïd le lieu du rassemblement est
symbolique le parlement est gelé depuis
plus de trois mois à la suite d'une
décision du chef de l'état désormais
doté des pleins pouvoirs
le locataire du palais de carthage est
pointé du doigt par les protestataires
il ya plutôt on n'est plus dans un pays
démocratique qui a donné toute une leçon
de 200 peuple pendant une dizaine
d'années pour la liberté là on est
vraiment dans une grande prison
vous parlez devient un crime parce que
monsieur le président ne veut pas nous
entendre et parce que monsieur le
président il est dans son cocon fait
personnel et il n'est pas du tout à
l'écouté de 100 pages jaunes en 2021 on
vit un coup d'état un véritable coup
d'état militaire policier seul état
policier qui revient un important
dispositif policier a été mis en place
pour l'occasion un tunis
dispositif destiné à bloquer les accès
au parlement le président kaïs sayyed
est de plus en plus critiqué des
élections sont réclamées notamment par
la gauche tunisienne à taradeau 4
aujourd'hui nous avons une initiative
politique à nous avons un modèle pour
vaincre cette crise ce modèle est basé
sur le droit des tunisiennes et des
tunisiens au vote dans le cadre
d'élections présidentielle et
législatives prématurée
en plus d'une crise politique le pays
est plongé dans une crise économique
avec une inflation estimée à 6% et un
taux de chômage de 18 % les tunisiens
veulent voir la situation changer
d'autres mobilisations pourraient avoir
lieu dans les jours à venir
la direction la libye chevaux le fils de
l'ancien dirigeant mouammar kadhafi est
candidat surprise à l'élection
présidentielle il a signé ce dimanche
les documents nécessaires à cette
officialisation
le scrutin est prévu le 24 décembre
prochain l'aboutissement d'un long
processus politique
réunis cette semaine à les pays
participants à la conférence sur la
libye se sont engagés à garantir des
élections libres et crédibles
ml vous gâche
soutenir le bon déroulement du processus
électoral et s'assurer de la tenue du
scrutin présidentiel prévu le 24
décembre prochain
deux objectifs fixés par la communauté
internationale pour mettre fin au
conflit en libye afin de donner une
impulsion au calendrier électoral
les dirigeants et ministres d'une
trentaine de pays étaient présents
emmanuel macron s'est réjoui de l'appui
unanime des participants
la communauté internationale à apporter
de manière unanime son soutien à ce
calendrier et l'organisation des
élections à cette date la clé est
maintenant dans le bon déroulement des
travaux et le rôle que les autorités et
institutions libyennes ont dans les
prochains jours et prochaines semaines
pour permettre d'avoir un processus
pleinement inclusif et une intégration
de toutes les parties prenantes qui le
souhaitent à ce processus électoral une
présidentielle puis les législatives
afin d'assurer un gouvernement à la
libye des élections très incertaine en
raison des divisions entre camps rivaux
de l'est et de l'ouest du pays mêlois
nul a rappelé toutes les parties
libyennes doivent participer à la mise
en place d'une transition pacifique
un appel entendu par le gouvernement
libyen
nous avons confirmé au cours de notre
réunion des éléments très importants
permettant d'assurer les élections dans
les conditions adéquates
des procédures pour garantir des
élections sans violation ni ingérence
politique et sous supervision
internationale
leur déclaration finale les participants
au prévenu qu'en cas d' obstacle au
processus électoral
il y aura des sanctions
il est important que toutes les parties
prenantes libyennes se mobilisent
résolument en faveur de l'organisation
d'élections présidentielle et
législatives libres régulières inclusive
et crédible le 24 décembre 2021 les
personnes ou entités à l'intérieur ou à
l'extérieur de la libye qui tenterait
d'entraver de remettre en cause de
manipuler ou de falsifier le processus
électoral et la transition politique
devront rendre des comptes et pourront
être inscrits sur la liste du comité des
sanctions de l'onu un processus
électoral déjà en cours le dépôt des
candidatures pour la présidentielle
s'est ouvert ce lundi le premier scrutin
au suffrage universel en libye des
élections censées mettre fin aux
divisions et tourner la page d'une
décennie de guerre civile
l'europe confrontée à une cinquième
vague de covin le nombre de cas de
contamination flambent à nouveau
conséquence les restrictions font leur
retour couvre-feu aux pays-bas bars
restaurants et magasins dits essentiels
doivent fermer à 20h 18h pour les
magasins non essentiel en autriche à
partir de demain confinement des
personnes non vaccinées ou qui ne sont
pas encore guéris du coc vide les
personnes concernées n'auront pas le
droit de quitter leur domicile sauf pour
faire leurs courses du sport ou bien
pour des soins médicaux la mesure
s'applique dès l'âge de 12 ans le
chancelier la firme la situation est
grave en écoute
nous avons décidé aujourd'hui qui à
partir de demain lundi il y aura un
confinement pour les personnes non
vaccinées en autriche cela signifie des
restrictions sur les sorties pour toutes
les personnes de plus de 12 ans les
lieux d'habitations privées ne pourront
être quitté que dans des cas
exceptionnels à l'avenir l'accès limité
aux personnes vaccinées ou aux personnes
ayant récupéré du coc u19 s'appliquera
dans le secteur du commerce de détail et
les personnes non vaccinées ne seront
plus autorisés à visiter les magasins
qui offrent plus que des fournitures de
base
sera contrôlé de manière très cohérente
et ce sera également sanctionné de
manière très cohérente je tiens à
remercier les policiers pour leur
engagement ici
un situation sanitaire également aux
préoccupante en belgique en une semaine
le toute contamination a augmenté de 39%
la france durcit donc ces conditions
d'entrée pour les personnes non
vaccinées en provenance de belgique il
faut désormais présenter un schéma
vaccinal incomplets ou bien un test pcr
ou antigénique négatif de moins de 24
heures pour passer la frontière la
mesure concerne également l'allemagne
l'allemagne la chancelière appelle un
effort national pour endiguer cette
nouvelle vague de qu'ovide aucune mesure
nationale n'est toutefois prises pour
inciter les réfractaires à la
vaccination mais des mesures au niveau
des régions et des villes à partir de
demain il faudra ainsi une preuve de
vaccination ou de guérison du coc vide à
berlin pour accéder au restaurant bar
salle de sport et salons de coiffure
samira chalet
une supplication pour inciter la
population à se faire vacciner et
accessoires de mode nous maintenant le
vaccin est là et tout ce que nous avons
à faire est de le saisir et le faire
rapidement je vous en prie participer et
essayer de convaincre vos parents et vos
amis si nous nous serrons les coudes si
nous pensons à nous protéger et à
prendre soin des autres
nous pouvons sauver beaucoup de choses
pour notre pays cet hiver
la résurgence de l'épidémie dans le pays
mais le système de santé sous tension
les admissions à l'hôpital sont en forte
hausse
40 % en une semaine très préoccupé les
autorités tentent par tous les moyens
d'encourager les réfractaires à se faire
vacciner toute la société semble
mobiliser à l'instar de ce chef
d'entreprise qui a décidé de faire
bouger les choses à sa manière tout le
monde qui peut produire une vaccination
complète d'ici le début de l'année
prochaine
recevra une prime de 5000 euros même
s'ils sont déjà vaccinés aujourd'hui ils
peuvent aussi espérer les 5000 euros et
ceux qui se feront vacciner d'ici là
recevront également un bonus de 5000
euros
une injection moyennant rétribution sur
le papier l'idée a tout pour plaire mais
pas sûr qu'elle séduit certains
irréductibles
j'ai juste pris les devants et je me
suis fait vacciner donc je ne le ferai
pas maintenant je ne pense pas que
l'argent fasse une différence pour ceux
qui ne veulent pas se faire vacciner
sur c'est une belle incitation pour les
employés c'est sûr eps mais je ne pense
pas que vous devriez vous faire vacciner
juste à cause de telles incitations pour
aller plus loin dans la citation le
gouvernement fédéral a restreint l'accès
aux grands événements personnes
vaccinées ou guéris du coc vide autre
mesure annoncée le retour des tests
gratuits depuis ce week end une manière
de casser la dynamique de l'épidémie en
identifiant attend les nouveaux
contaminés en allemagne 67 % de la
population est totalement vacciner au
cours de l'été dernier l'institut de
veille sanitaire robert koch avait
évoqué un objectif de 75 % avant
l'automne en martinique l'obligation
vaccinale des soignants est reportée au
31 décembre date qui correspond à la fin
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire dans le
département le gouvernement suit ainsi
les préconisations de la mission de
médiation alors qu'une intersyndicale du
chu s'oppose à cette obligation ainsi
qu'au passé ni terre à les ministres de
la santé chez des outre mer olivier
ferrand et sébastien lecornu eux ont
retenu précisément deux dispositions la
gratuité générale des tests maintenir
jusqu'à la fin de l'année ainsi qu'un
schéma vaccinal à complet exigé pour les
personnels à deux soirs à la même
échéance du 31 décembre réaction de
magali zamor secrétaire général la cgtm
santé membre de cette intersyndicale la
martinique
sarralbe pas l'emblème de fonds sont
toujours aux obligations merci des aléas
sanitaires
aujourd'hui nous avons connaissance de
gouvernement a adopté
communication voilà est et c'est dommage
que nous avons considérons que c'est un
manque de respect vis-à-vis de nos
martinique et toutes les personnes
qu'elle a beaucoup d'incohérences
aujourd'hui nous savons qu'il ya des
ruptures de la confiance en tout cas de
l'outre-mer vis-à-vis de ce gouvernement
qui n'arrête pas de nous mentir il
n'avait pas de viande et annoncé que le
cap à ses paroles le taux de non
vaccinés est important ne parle pas de
38 % de
personnes vaccinées dont vous voyez que
aujourd'hui les faits sont là et on ne
peut pas aujourd'hui de l'anah
constituent des souhaits ou à penser de
pouvoir travailler ou blessés ou bien
les services sans les personnels
soignants ce n'est pas possible
premier résultat en bulgarie le pays ils
votaient ce dimanche pour les troisièmes
législatives de l'année surprise selon
des estimations à la sortie des urnes un
nouveau mouvement anticorruption lancée
par un duo d'entrepreneurs quadragénaire
ford aux états unis talonnerait les
conservateurs la formation continue de
changement recueillerait plus de 23% des
suffrages presque à égalité avec le
parti conservateur germes de l'ancien
premier ministre boïko borisov fort de
près de 25% des voix parti qui ne
devrait toutefois pas être en mesure de
gouverner faute d'alliés les bulgares et
lisez aussi leurs présidents vont même
d'un radeff qu'on avait à sa succession
fait la course en tête à l'issue du
premier tour avec 49% des suffrages
contre 25% pour son plus proche
concurrent
le recteur de l'université de sofia
nastasa stagaires 10 chf appuyé par gm à
bruxelles la prépare de nouvelles
sanctions à l'encontre de minsk les
ministres des affaires étrangères de
lieux se réunissent deux en lieu accuse
le président alexandre loukachenko
d'être responsable de la crise
migratoire qui se joue à la frontière
entre la pologne et la biélorussie
la situation actuelle est inacceptable
et doit cesser les gens ne doivent pas
être utilisés comme arme c'est ce qu'a
déclaré dans un tweet le chef de la
diplomatie européenne
nous allons donner le feu vert à un
élargissement du cadre juridique de nos
sanctions contre la biélorussie pour
qu'on puisse l'appliquer à tous ceux qui
participent au trafic de migrants vers
ce pays par exemple les compagnies
aériennes ou les agences de voyages
impliqué en interdisant leur dirigeant
de voyager et en gelant leurs actifs en
europe
la chef de la diplomatie européenne qui
pour la première fois depuis le début de
la crise s'est entretenu par téléphone
dans la journée avec le ministre un
biélorusse des affaires étrangères
toutes sanctions seraient sans espoir et
contre productive l'a averti ce dernier
alors que des milliers de migrants kampf
aux portes de l'europe des candidats à
l'exil en provenance du moyen-orient à
les autorités polonaises ont renforcé la
sécurité pour les empêcher d'entrer sur
le territoire côté vélo aussi de l'aide
humanitaire a été acheminé des migrants
à la recherche d'un avenir meilleur
c'est le cas des parents donnent à ton
fils ont quitté le kurdistan irakien où
il n'y avait pas de traitement médical
pour leur fils
étude et et billettique avec moi vous à
vue
dr
guy turcotte
[Musique]
le chemin a été long pour nhat hanh et
sa famille depuis sa région d'origine en
irak jusqu'à la frontière polono
biélorusse avec un objectif celui
d'entrer dans l'union européenne
pour ses parents l'europe peut lui
offrir le traitement dont il a besoin
quand il est né il avait une maladie
dans les jambes nous avons essayé très
fort d'obtenir un traitement à
l'étranger mais nous n'avons pas obtenu
la permission de quitter le pays en
allemagne nous avons reçu une offre de
traitement mais nous n'avons pas été
autorisés à quitter le kurdistan après
plusieurs années d'interdiction de
sortie les médecins nous ont dit que
nous devions l'amputer des jambes
nhat hanh est né avec une maladie
incurable qui l'a privé de l'usagé de
ses jambes pour marcher il utilise des
prothèses qu'il doit changer tous les
six mois en raison de sa croissance
une situation difficile à accepter la
vie au kurdistan est trop dure il ne
peut pas aller à l'école ou jouer dans
la cour de récréation les autres enfants
l'insultent parce qu'il est handicapé
depuis plusieurs jours nhat hanh et sa
famille sont dans la tente comme des
centaines d'autres réfugiés bloqués à la
frontière dans des conditions très
précaires sur fond de tensions entre la
biélorussie et l'union européenne
un affrontement qui laisse tous ces
migrants désoeuvrés à l' approche de
l'hiver
boris johnson reconnaît une certaine
déception à l'issue de la coop 26 autres
de la conférence sur le climat le
premier ministre britannique espérait
que les pays aille plus loin pour
réduire le réchauffement climatique un
accord a bien été conclu hier par près
de 200 pays mais en accord pas
franchement à la hauteur des enjeux
selon les observateurs solène gaudin
réduire le charbon et les subventions
aux énergies fossiles des engagements
arraché au terme de longues négociations
loin de l'ambition initiale de la coop
26 de l'aveu même de son président
je suis déçu comme je lui dis de l'issue
de ce processus mais nous avons réussi à
conclure un accord historique
néanmoins nous avons un texte sur le
charbon un texte sur la réduction
progressive du charbon non traités et je
pense que de nombreuses personnes se
réjouiront du fait comment cela a été
réalisé
parmi les objectifs de départ en finir
avec le charbon mais sous la pression de
l'inde et de la chine
cette sortie s'est transformé en simple
réduction de l'exploitation de ce
combustible autres ambitions revues à la
baisse le pacte de glasgow ne garantit
pas de contenir le réchauffement
climatique dû aux émissions de gaz à
effet de serre à 1,5 degré il ne porte
pas non plus d'engagement financier pour
aider les pays pauvres premiers impactés
par le réchauffement de la planète
un texte décevant pour les ong et les
observateurs ont un texte qui est très
faible même s'ils mentionnent la
réduction du charbon finalement au
départ on était parti sur une sortie des
énergies fossiles bien je pense que
l'accord est trop doux est trop faible
je pense que les jeunes s'attendait à ce
que leurs dirigeants viennent ici et d
écoute eux est patent l'industrie des
combustibles fossiles
en marge de la déclaration finale
d'autres accords ont été scellées à
cette coque 26 par un nombre limité de
signataires une centaine de pays se sont
ainsi engagés à réduire leurs émissions
de méthane de 30% d'ici à 2030 un accord
a également été trouvé pour mettre fin
d'ici à 2022 au financement des projets
d'énergies fossiles sans technique de
capture de carbone
quelques avancées donc depuis les
accords de paris
même si glasgow referme la page de la
coop 26 dans la tiédeur
un déception aussi pour le secrétaire
général de l'onu s'il concède quelques
avancées ce n'est pas assez selon lui
écouter
les textes adoptés sont un compromis il
reflète les intérêts la situation dans
des contradictions et l'état de la
volonté politique actuelle dans le monde
notre fragile planète ne tient qu'à un
fil la catastrophe climatique frappe
toujours à la porte il est temps de
passer en mode urgence ou bien autre
chance d'atteindre la neutralité carbone
sera nul
un corps retrouvé après un changement de
dernière minute accordé à lempdes sur le
charbon le pays est l'un des plus gros
producteurs et consommateurs au monde
d'une énergie polluante à ce cas
s'ajoute un trafic très dense et des
feux agricoles allumées chaque hiver
conséquence new delhi est asphyxié en ce
moment même par un nuage de pollution la
capitale indienne ferme ces écoles dès
demain et envisage même à un confinement
[Musique]
oh
beaucoup
[Musique]
m ans
oh
et
où
oui
[Musique]
où
washington appelle la cub a autorisé la
manifestation de demain l'opposition
prévoit une marche dont pleure pour
demander la libération de prisonniers à
les autorités ont interdit tout
rassemblement
elle accuse les états unis
d'instrumentaliser les mobilisations
pour déstabiliser le pouvoir julien
albert
défendre la révolution c'est la
justification avancée par michael dias
cannelle le président cubain pour
interdire la manifestation de lundi un
rassemblement organisé par l'opposition
pour réclamer le changement et la
libération de ce qu'il qualifie de
prisonniers politiques
il s'agit des manifestants emprisonnés
après les mobilisations inédit du 11
juillet l'union garcia le principal
organisateur du rassemblement et figure
de l'opposition cubaine s'est vu menacé
d'être arrêté s'il persistait dans ses
appels à manifester il s'est donc
résolue à marcher seul ce dimanche une
rose blanche à la main afin d'éviter
tout débordement une initiative là aussi
interdite j'ai été prévenue par les
autorités que j'allais aller en prison
qu'ils ne baisseront pas manifester même
de la nouvelle façon que j'ai annoncée
c'est à dire marcher seul
déterminé il ne compte pas abandonner et
maintient vouloir manifester en cash au
milan ac à karbala fabre au bella center
où est remarquable
je vais marcher quoi qu'il arrive je ne
les laisserai pas m'empêcher d'être avec
les gens le jour de la marche je vais
également démontré qu'ils n'ont pas
déclaré cela illégal pour les raisons
évoquées c'est parce qu'il ne faut pas
disposée à permettre quoi que ce soit
pas même la mode rex'pression d'un
citoyen cubain qui s'opposent à eux ou
qui a une pensée contraire ou qui veut
simplement participer dans d'autres
points de vue dans le pays
le gouvernement cubain lui y voit une
ingérence politique extérieure
il accuse les états unis d'être liés à
cette opposition est de vouloir
déstabiliser cuba
nous empêcheront toute tentative
d'ingérence
d'intervention ou d'intervention
humanitaire ou toute forme
d'intervention contre notre indépendance
et notre souveraineté que nous défendons
depuis 60 ans et que nous défendrons au
prix de nos vies
des tensions dans un contexte économique
compliqué il est touché par de graves
pénuries de nourriture et de médicaments
exacerbés par une baisse du tourisme duo
kobe 19 et au renforcement des sanctions
économiques américaines
hollande la mutinerie dans la prison de
guayaquil en équateur des renforts
militaires ont été envoyés au tour du
centre pénitentiaire 68 détenus y sont
morts 25 autres blessées lors
d'affrontements entre gangs rivaux des
armes blanches armes à feu et des
explosifs ont été utilisés
les autorités ont repris le contrôle de
la prison hier soir près de 900
policiers ont été mobilisés dont 500 à
l'intérieur de la prison écoutez sa
réaction de proches de détenus
voulons au moins savoir nous voulons
qu'ils fassent quelque chose contre
cette angoisse qu éprouvent tous les
pères toutes les mères il ya une liste
de personnes mortes et le président ne
fait rien l'état ne fait rien il a des
enfants il a un père et si c'étaient ses
enfants qui étaient là
où est le président de ce pays en
espagne à chercher du travail pour les
équatoriens sans s'occuper de leur pays
des jeunes qui sont là des vieux malades
ouais cynthia viteri où est le ministre
de l'intérieur et de la justice faites
moi une faveur nous sommes tous humains
nous sommes déterminés à mettre tout le
monde en prison tout le monde peut être
mis en prison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et le reste de l'actualité
internationale en bref et en images
rassemblement à bangkok en thaïlande
les protestataires dénoncent une
décision de la cour constitutionnelle
qui estime que trois militants tentaient
de renverser le gouvernement
ces derniers réclament une réforme de la
monarchie les manifestants ont remis une
déclaration de protestation aux
autorités de l'ambassade allemande
l'allemagne où le roi aurait récemment
voyagé information qui n'a pas été
officiellement confirmée
à jalalabad en afghanistan les
manifestants réclament tous aux
autorités de la nourriture et de l'aide
humanitaire selon une récente estimation
près de 23 millions d'un second serait
concerné par la crise alimentaire qui
sévit depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir des
talibans la manifestation s'est déroulée
sous leur contrôle
en hand d'importantes inondations ont
fait 14 morts dans le sud du pays ces
cinq derniers jours il est tombé
l'équivalent de près d'un mois
précipitation des véhicules ont été
submergés des maisons inondées depuis
une semaine déjà des évacuations sont en
cours selon les experts la météo la
pluie devrait cesser dans les jours qui
viennent
et c'est la fin cette édition se
retrouve dans une trentaine de minutes
pour un nouveau genre à la totale art
[Musique]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on disait
dans les grandes entreprises
multinationales de saint gobain russie
ukraine on a beaucoup dit que bon
l'ouest et caïcos l'eau mais que l'est
et paul bert moi je suis convaincu à
titre personnel que il faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc les plus observés aux il
faut réduire les émissions de carbone
dans les pays en développement sur
partout partout vous avez construit des
vignes décarbonés vos des usines où on
aimait